durante el año pasado una agencia de
viajes ha recolectado información del
número de boletos individuales que se
venden por su producto estrella un
crucero al mediterráneo' la información
mensual de las ventas de los boletos se
muestra abajo cuáles son los mejores y
peores meses para la venta de cruceros
lo que nos muestran aquí abajo es una
gráfica de pastel y se le llama así
porque es redondo y está dividido en
rebanadas aunque algunas veces se les
llama gráfica circular pero es mucho más
conocido por gráfica de pastel y se
refiere a las ventas mensuales de
boletos por lo que cada una de estas
rebanadas representa un mes en la venta
de boletos por ejemplo esta rebanada
representa las ventas del mes de enero
la forma en la que está configurada esta
gráfica de pastel es que cada rebanada
va a ser más grande o más pequeña
dependiendo del número de boletos
vendidos en ese meses por ejemplo en
enero se vendió el 18 por ciento de
todas las ventas anuales si sumamos
todos estos porcentajes nos debe de dar
el cien por ciento y aquí nos dicen que
vendieron 18 por ciento del total y no
sólo eso el tema
de esta rebanada debe ser equivalente al
18 por ciento del total del círculo o
del pastel es literalmente el 18 por
ciento del pastel y ya que vemos esto
vamos a concentrarnos en lo que nos
preguntan cuáles son los mejores y
peores meses de las ventas del crucero
el mejor mes pues es obviamente en el
que tienen más ventas por lo que vamos a
ver cuál es la rebanada más grande aquí
el porcentaje mayor de la venta de
boletos por meses y obviamente estamos
viendo que la rebanada más grande es la
de enero y no necesitamos ver el
porcentaje sino simplemente observar la
proporción de la rebanada en esta
gráfica de pastel para darnos cuenta que
esta de enero es la que es más grande
por lo tanto este es el mejor mes para
la venta de cruceros ya que se vendió el
18 por ciento y vemos que este
porcentaje es mucho más grande que los
demás en los otros meses pero como les
digo es evidente simplemente viendo la
gráfica y ahora cuál es el peor mes pues
vemos lo contrario cuál es la rebanada
más chiquita bueno revisamos las
rebanadas
y las más chiquitas encontramos que son
las de julio y junio los meses de verano
mayo también tiene una rebanada chiquita
pero las más chicas son las de junio y
julio que corresponden al 3 por ciento
de las ventas totales cada uno aquí es
donde los números son útiles porque al
ver la gráfica quizás no estemos tan
seguros del tamaño de estas rebanaditas
y por eso los números nos ayudan a
aclarar esas diferencias y por lo tanto
los meses de junio y julio son los
peores para la venta de cruceros y esta
es la respuesta a esta pregunta a los
peores meses para la venta de cruceros o
para la venta de boletos de cruceros son
junio y julio el mejor es obviamente
enero y aunque no nos lo preguntan de la
gráfica podemos ver que el siguiente mes
que es mejor para la venta es el mes de
noviembre con 13 por ciento y le sigue
diciembre con 12 por ciento en general
podemos ver que los meses de invierno
tienen una mejor venta de boletos para
el crucero que los meses en los que hace
más calor y yo creo que es porque la
gente busca alejarse del frío